pour maria ce 14 août et celui d'un
triste anniversaire
il y a 6 ans jour pour jour sa fille
aurélia varlet 32 ans était tué à coup
de fusil par son ex-compagnon une date
difficile à supporter d'autant que cette
maman attend toujours des explications
pour comprendre pourquoi aurélia n'a pas
été mieux protégés par les services de
l'état
ce que j'ai envie de dire oui c'est de
la colère parce que là qu'est ce que je
voudrais moi que tout s'arrête parce que
qu'on ait une vie normale aussi bien mon
fils moi mon ex mari
je voudrais que ça s'arrête et que le
gouvernement prenne une décision pour
nous parce que notre souffrance elle est
là tous les jours tous les jours
maria est épaulé par son fils giovanni
pour mener cette bataille car la
précédente compagne du meurtrier avait
déposé trois plaintes dont une pour
enlèvement tout classer sans suite
ce qui avait conduit le ministère de la
justice à reconnaître la faute de l'état
en 2015
deux ans plus tard gérard collomb
demande une enquête à l'igpn pour savoir
si deux fonctionnaires de police et de
gendarmerie
sollicité à l'époque avait fauté par
négligence bouclé depuis mars
cette enquête n'a toujours pas été rendu
public
moi ce que j'attends du ministère de
l'intérieur c'est des sanctions et un
rapport complet pour comprendre comment
le meurtrier pendant tant d'années a été
complètement
protéger parce que c'est ça c'est de la
protection qu'il devait y avoir une
perquisition d'armes à feu au domicile
du meurtrier
elle n'a jamais été exécutée elle a été
demandée elle n'a jamais été exécutée ci
aurait eu cette perquisition
ma soeur elle sera à côté de moi sur ce
banc voyez et ça c'est ça en fait oui en
fait oui on revient sur un sentiment de
colère parce que parce qu'on a plus quoi
après on va pleurer
on n'a pas assez pleuré s'il n'est pas
entendu d'ici le mois de septembre
giovanni varlet envisage de mener une
grève de la faim devant le siège du
ministère de l'intérieur